[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est une édition spéciale de
sciences publiques que je vous propose
ce vendredi soir pour analyser les
conséquences de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel elle est tombée il y a
quelques minutes à peine les 9 sages de
la rue Montpensier ont donc validé le
report de l'âge légal à 64 ans mais si
dispositions du texte sont rejetées
notamment l'index senior concernant le
référendum d'initiative partagée il est
invalidé par le Conseil les parties de
gauche au Sénat avaient anticipé cette
décision en déposant hier une deuxième
mouture de leur projet et le Conseil
constitutionnel donne rendez-vous le 3
mai pour cette décision sur le RIB
deuxième formule on va évidemment
débattre de ces informations d'abord
avec mes invités politiques la
communiste Eliane assassy Roger carochi
pour les républicains et puis Martin
lévrier pour le parti Renaissance qui va
arriver dans quelques minutes je
recevrai ensuite des experts la
constitutionnaliste politologue
spécialiste des négociations sociales on
se projettera un peu plus dans l'avenir
on dévoilera notamment les stratégies à
venir de l'exécutif des oppositions et
deux l'Inter syndical je commence tout
de suite avec mes invités et avec vous
Ilan assassy est-ce que vous êtes
finalement déçu par cette décision du
Conseil constituant est-ce que vous y
attendiez c'était un peu ce qu'on
imaginait
plus que plus que déçu je suis en colère
je respecte bien évidemment les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
mais je crois que lui aussi alors je
sais bien que les membres du Conseil
constitutionnel font le droit et rien
que le droit mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que des millions de nos
concitoyens sont expriment leur colère
face à cette réforme et je pense qu'il a
pris aujourd'hui une responsabilité
historique en invalidant simplement
quelques mesures de de ce texte mais en
gardant quand même ce qui provoque
justement la colère c'est le recul de
l'âge de départ à la à la retraite donc
voilà et on ne va pas s'étonner si la
colère monte dans le pays s'il y aura de
nouvelles manifestations pour exiger
malgré la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel le retrait de ce de ce
texte les Français n'en veulent pas
Martin léoyer bonsoir bien sûr est-ce
que vous êtes soulagés ce soir de cette
digestion
j'allais dire sa confirme la solidité
nos institutions la solidité notre
démocratie tous les mécanismes mis en
place dans la Constitution ont été
étudiés suivies les uns après les autres
on arrive à la fin d'un cycle le Conseil
constitutionnel visiblement excusez-moi
mais je viens d'arriver valide en grande
partie si j'ai bien compris en tout cas
la mesure principale
à 64 ans j'en prends acte c'est le rôle
de conseil constitutionnel qui n'est pas
un organe politique qui a ce rôle de
Sage j'allais dire dans notre dans notre
pays j'en prends acte et je prends comme
tel et pourtant ayan assassin dit à
l'instant il y a une colère populaire
qui va sans doute s'exprimer à la suite
de cette décision la démocratie est
ainsi faite que le Parlement doit jouer
son rôle que l'ensemble d'institutions
doivent jouer leur rôle c'est
l'institutions jouent leur rôle le
Parlement a joué son rôle le Parlement
représente le peuple et donc nous devons
nous incliner de devant cette décision
j'entends si vous voulez de le
mécontentement parfois la colère de
certains mais la démocratie c'est avant
tout le respect d'institutions et c'est
aussi et surtout le respect du courage
qu'il faut avoir en politique et que
malheureusement il n'y a pas eu assez
souvent Roger caoutchi comment vous
analysez vous cette décision du Conseil
constitution on parlera ensuite du
contexte particulier quand même il y a
le déploiement le dispositif positif
policier autour de du Palais Royal et de
la c'est autre chose mais quand même on
y viendra parce que c'est pas forcément
rassurant sur l'état du pays mais
comment vous analysez cette décision du
conseil je n'attendais rien d'autre du
Conseil on savait qu'il n'allait pas
censurer l'ensemble on savait qu'il
allait censurer quelques cavaliers je le
regrette d'autant plus que les mesures
que les républicains avaient initié
notamment pour les seniors
en réalité qu'est ce qu'a fait le
Conseil constitutionnel aujourd'hui il a
dit au président de la République
écouter mais bien aimable c'est pas à
nous de décider nous nous disons que
juridiquement ça tient mais le la
relation politique la relation sociale
c'est à vous de la prendre c'est pas ne
nous faites pas porter le chapeau d'une
réforme que nous n'avons pas initié nous
vous disons seulement juridiquement tout
ça tient à peu près mais est-ce que
politiquement socialement vous avez à
prendre des initiatives à faire bouger
les lignes c'est à vous d'en décider pas
à nous conseils constitutionnel qui
n'est pas là pour ça donc en réalité on
a simplement
conforter le fait que les critiques sur
le côté juridique ne tiennent pas mais
en revanche est-ce qu'on a avancé sur
l'acceptation politique et sociale non
et quand j'entends les syndicats dire
qu'ils ne souhaitent pas aller chez le
président de la République le 18 là on
va vers quelque chose qui va ressembler
un blocage il faut que le Président de
la République trouve des initiatives
laquelle je n'en sais rien c'est à lui
de vouloir la prendre est-ce que c'est
un changement est-ce que il y a des
éléments à revoir sur cette réforme
c'est à lui de voir mais en tout cas on
ne peut pas avoir un pays où il n'y a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
pas de dialogue social et pas de blocage
entre l'exécutif et les corps
intermédiaires à un moment il faut
trouver une ouverture elle arrive pas
trop tard cette main tendue par le
Président de la République à
l'intersyndicale elle serait arrivée
plus tôt elle aurait posé un problème
dans le déroulement logique de la
démarche d'une loi le président de la
demande c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
une demande qu'on pouvait écouter mais
on ne pouvait pas l'appliquer si le
président de la République s'était mêlé
du débat parlementaire que nous répondit
la séparation des pouvoirs exige dans ce
pays c'est ce qui fait la force de nos
démocratie donc non le président de la
République était dans son rôle
d'attendre je rappelle quand même ça me
paraît important mais je quand on parle
de négociation de quelques natures que
ce soit pour qu'une négociation avance
il faut que tout le monde fasse au moins
un pas
à l'heure qu'il est tous les pas qui ont
été faits sont du côté du gouvernement
65 ans à 64 ans trois mois de
négociation avec les syndicats avec un
travail sur les syndicats sur les
mesures sur un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été reprises en particulier sur
la pénibilité et soit les seniors qui
ont été reprises à la demande des
syndicats tous ces gestes là sont allés
dans un sens je n'ai pas vu un seul
geste
peut-être mais il faut vraiment je vais
vous donner la parole
rapidement un mot non faut rappeler que
c'est concertation elles n'ont pas été
elles ont duré à peine trois mois et on
n'a pas discuté de l'essentiel dans
certains concertation le projet de loi
n'était pas dévoilé il a été dévoilé
plus tard il n'a pas été dévoilé au
syndicat pendant on a fait les choses à
l'envers on veut on invite les syndicats
à discuter et les syndicalistes mais
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans votre projet de
loi on dit on vous dira plus tard mais
comment vous voulez l'améliorer donc il
y a eu une élection présidentielle ou
les choses avaient été clairement dit
non puisque c'est passé
d'évolution ça veut dire que les
évolutions je n'ai pas eu des syndicats
en cours je ne remets pas du tout en
cause le fait que Emmanuel Macron avait
annoncé qu'il ferait sa dernière on ne
peut pas parler de négociation quand on
met pas tout sur la table il y a une
conception du dialogue social une
conception du rapport avec les corps
intermédiaires par cette majorité depuis
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron qui la
théorisé en disant les syndicats sont
alors place dans les entreprises ils
sont moins légitimes pour discuter des
grands enjeux nationaux et il l'assume
mais donc on le voit ça coinceau avec
les républicains avec les les syndicats
et et ça n'a pas marché évidemment pour
répondre mais je voudrais aussi quel
lien voilà ce qu'elle pense de ce déjà
rendez-vous quasiment quai enfin voilà
c'est ça aura sans doute mieux après
mais pour l'instant on est dans ce
combat le gouvernement et le président
de la République avec créé les
conditions pour qu'il n'y ait pas
justement de dialogue approfondie avec
les organisations syndicales rappelons
nous quand même que la première ministre
a annoncé le projet de loi et son
véhicule le 10 janvier on est bien
d'accord le 10 janvier et que entre le
10 janvier et les débuts des discussions
Parlement on ne peut pas dire qu'il y a
eu des discussions approfondie et de
l'écoute aussi attentive aux
propositions qui ont été faites par
l'Inter syndical ce n'est pas vrai il
n'y a pas eu de prise en compte y
compris moi comme président de groupe
comme président de groupe j'ai été reçu
par Madame borne aimablement gentiment
c'est déjà pas mal mais elle n'a pris
aucunement en compte une seule de nos
propositions
fût-elle non révolutionnaires voyez elle
était voilà donc on ne peut pas dire
qu'il y a eu un débat et moi je je
remarqué que depuis le premier
quinquennat le président de la
République a tout fait pour éteindre la
parole des corps intermédiaires dont les
syndicats et qu'il est exactement dans
la même logique je trouve quand même
assez inquiétant que le Président de la
République propose aujourd'hui alors je
veux bien entendu il fallait attendre la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel etc
au syndicat de le recevoir le 18 bien
Monseigneur ce n'est pas du tout mais
bien Monseigneur mais les syndicats ont
aussi des modalités des modalités qu'il
faut respecter d'autant que c'est inédit
c'est une inter syndicale
unie depuis le début des des
mobilisations sur
président de la République quand même il
ne la SNAP pas il dit simplement nous
avons un grand rendez-vous le 1er mai et
nous vous rencontrerons après le premier
mai c'est ce qu'ils ont dit aujourd'hui
donc il ne snopent pas le président de
la République d'autant que oui d'accord
mais d'autant que le Président de la
République n'a pas écouté aussi leur
demande
d'entrevue il y a quelques semaines
comme il n'a pas accepté notre demande
d'entrevue des parlementaires nous lui
avons adressé un courrier pour lui
demander mais il y avait encore des
choses à discuter bon il y avait encore
des choses à discuter
et tout à créer une crise démocratique
je sais bien que certains ne veulent pas
l'entendre et ensuite démocratique
aujourd'hui dans le pays
ça changera pas grand chose d'ailleurs
premier point on subit l'affaiblissement
des formations politiques du Parlement
des syndicats depuis 5-6 ans ça c'est
clair que le côté un peu marbréen
jupitérien ça n'aide pas pour le
dialogue mais d'un Conseil
constitutionnel aussi
il y a à peine un Français sur deux qui
fait confiance
impartiales les temps qui courent toute
la chaîne de la décision est contestée
voilà parce que quand vous contestez le
Parlement les syndicats les parties les
machins bah les Français se disent tout
doit être contestable allez on y va mais
le ce que je dis aussi bien Éliane qu'à
Martin lévrier que franchement bon voilà
on est quand même à peine mi-avril que
le président République et des torts je
suis le premier à dire j'avais déjà dit
il y a un mois qui devrait recevoir
l'intersyndicale parce que ça n'est pas
possible qu'on ait une situation de
blocage de dire c'est pas mon rôle si
c'est son rôle aussi mais deuxième
élément là la réponse est syndicats à la
limite qui disent on doit d'abord se
réunir voir les conditions voir ce que
vous avez à nous proposer je comprends
mais qui dit pas avant le premier mai
sous-entendu 15 jours mais dans la
situation de blocage
dans laquelle est le pays on ne peut pas
rester encore 15 jours en se disant on
sait pas ce qui va se passer en fait ça
c'est pas tenable Martin lévrier je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec la fin du
propos de Roger Caro non non je
maintiens que chacun doit être à sa
place et à son rôle et quand on est dans
la dans la période parlementaire le
président doit attendre la fin de la
période parlementaire sinon on mélange
les genres et ça serait encore plus
affaiblir ce que vous venez de dire sur
la démocratie sur le Parlement alors
dire que c'est depuis 5-6 ans que le
démocratie minimale parce que les partis
politiques s'effrontent comme si c'était
Emmanuel Macron qui effondré parti
politique je crois malheureusement que
les partis politiques effectivement
s'effondrent mais je les invite très
fortement ça fait 6 ans que je le dis à
se regarder d'abord en interne plutôt de
chercher un bouc émissaire et c'est top
parce qu'en cherchant un bouc émissaire
on ne voit pas les vrais problèmes donc
faites très attention à ça infini je
crois qu'il est très important
aujourd'hui que les syndicats prennent
la mesure de l'appel du président à les
rencontrer parce que je crois qu'il faut
qu'il y ait des gestes dans tous les
sens d'apaisement aujourd'hui pour le
bien de tous une guéguerre c'est un
sujet très sérieux et moi je pense qu'il
est très important vu que syndicat ne se
met pas dans une posture et se disent il
tend la main nous allons voir et
construisons quelque chose alors on va
évidemment y revenir mais je vous
propose de rejoindre tout de suite dans
le quartier du Palais Royal tout près de
du siège du Conseil constitutionnel
Mathias qui est avec Hugo Lemonnier sur
place
sport Mathias pour voilà nous redire
nous donner même quelques détails sur la
décision des 9 sages de la rue de
Montpensier
elle était attendu et le Conseil
constitutionnel a décidé de ne pas
censurer ce texte de la réforme des
retraites il a simplement donc décidé de
censurer les cavaliers sociaux on
l'avait énormément évoqué ces dernières
semaines six groupes sont donc concernés
l'article 2 relatif à l'index senior
l'article 3 au contrat de travail senior
il y a également d'autres dispositions
notamment concernant des critères de
pénibilité voilà donc ça c'est pour la
première décision prise par le Conseil
constitutionnel la deuxième concernant
le référendum d'initiative partagée et
bien le Conseil constitutionnel a décidé
de ne pas retenir ce premier RIB qui a
été déposé qui a été envoyé par
l'Assemblée nationale au prétexte que le
Conseil constitutionnel juge que ne
porte pas sur une réforme relative à la
politique sociale de à la nation le
Conseil constitutionnel qui est à
présent va examiner le deuxième RIP
poser cette fois par le Sénat et qui
statura donc dessus le 3 mai prochain
merci beaucoup Mathias Arès donc avec
Hugo le meunier aux conseils
concisionnel Roger caoutchi j'imagine
que vous regrettez que finalement
plusieurs amendements apportés par la
majorité LR ici au Sénat viennent d'être
aussi attendez un peu viennent d'être
auto qui ça déséquilibre le texte pour
vous ça ne déséquilibre pas le texte ça
le durcit puisque par définition ces
amendements étaient destinés à améliorer
la situation des seniors dans le monde
du travail était sur les critères de
pénibilité étaient également
c'était des éléments pour justement que
les gens se disent en cas de carrière
pénible en cas de difficulté il y a
quand même des adoucisseurs dans ce
texte on savait soyons francs on savait
dans le débat sénatorial on savait que
certains d'entre eux étaient très
limites
par rapport à un pdfss et pouvait être
cavalier sociaux donc le Conseil
constitutionnel les a rejetés ça nous
laisse le texte d'origine brut ce qui
veut dire que forcément alors le
ministère c'était déjà pressé lorsqu'on
avait évoqué le fait qu'il soit censuré
de nous dire il serait repris dans un
texte travail sauf que le texte travail
on nous l'annonce pour le mois de juin
sans concertation avec les syndicats
avant ou à peine un mois ça n'est pas
tenable donc faudrait que tout le monde
se mette autour de la table et se disent
bon si on faisait les choses dans les
règles en respectant le dialogue
classique et la procédure classique ce
serait plus simple pour tout le monde
mais la réaction Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y
a quelques minutes sur son compte
Twitter la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel montre qu'il est plus
attentif aux besoins de la monarchie
présidentielle qu'à ceux du peuple
souverain la lutte continue Édouard
rassembler ses forces et bien assassies
est-ce que vous reprenez ces termes à
votre compte ou pas je vous ai donné les
miens
vous n'allez pas juste vous jusque là ce
que j'ai donné mais non mais la parole
de Mélenchon appartient à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'appartient pas
monarchie monarchie c'est quoi le terme
exact monarchie présidentielle
on passe ce qui n'appartient pas autre
réaction si la Marine Le Pen et
également sur Twitter si la décision du
Conseil constitutionnelle clos la
séquence institutionnelle le sort
politique de la réforme des retraites
n'est pas scellé le peuple ayant
toujours le dernier mot il lui
appartiendra de préparer l'alternance
qui reviendra sur cette réforme
inutile et un juge je veux bien vous
entendre aussi là-dessus est-ce que
finalement c'est pas le mouvement du
rassemblement national et Marine Le Pen
qui sortent les grands gagnants de cette
séquence politique écoutez on va pas si
j'ai bien écouté ce que vous dites c'est
que Marine Le Pen se projette sur la
présidentielle de de 2027 voilà c'est sa
seule préoccupation nous notre
préoccupations c'est le retrait de cette
réforme donc on joue pas dans la même
cour quand même donc voilà je je trouve
que c'est limite indécent qu'elle puisse
tenir genre de propos elle est bien loin
des préoccupations des plus de 90% de
Français qui sont contre cette réforme
je reviens sur le déséquilibre éventuel
de la réforme Martin lévrier est-ce que
finalement la décision du Conseil
consuel on parle souvent de sucré salé
du fait qu'on avait rajouté des mesures
plus sucrées plus sociales dans par
rapport au taxi initial ben ce sont
celles qui sont
alors partir au toquer ce soir donc le
texte comme le dit Roger caoutchi de
fait il devient plus dur et peut-être
qu'il va nourrir une colère populaire
encore s'éteindre
les parties pénibilités qui ont été
retirés parce que là on sait pas du tout
lesquelles pour l'instant sur les
seniors j'ai bien compris que les deux
les deux propositions avaient été
retirées et si c'était une opportunité
cette loi de cette loi travail
pour moi est indispensable et même
excessivement importantes parce que
vous savez ce reproche
se reproche de la Charrière avant les
boeufs je me rappelle je venais tout
juste d'être élu en 2017 qu'on nous l'a
fait
sur la façon nous avions abordé le
combat contre le chômage en commençant
par les lois travail suivi de la loi sur
la formation professionnelle et sur
l'apprentissage et on avait dit c'est la
priorité des priorités parce que c'est
ça qui va enclencher la baie du chômage
et j'avais entendu le même discours la
charrue avant les bœufs machin et bien
nous avions eu raison moi je pense que
les deux sont liés je pense qu'il est
indispensable de faire une loi travail
parce qu'effectivement le rapport au
monde du train au travail a changé et de
façon très intéressante en plus qui a un
levier formidable de réflexion qui doit
être enclenchée et moi j'espère vraiment
que finalement ce côté un peu sucré mais
mais je suis pas sûr qu'il fut si sucré
parce que si on parle des seniors par
exemple
l'hypothèse de travail qui avait été
reprise dans le corps c'était sur la
base d'un chômage à 4,5%. si on parle
d'un chômage à 4,5% c'est que le
problème des seniors est réglé
donc je pense que c'est plus dans une
loi travail parce que on pensait qu'on
allait arriver dans la loi travail et
c'est donc dans cette loi travail qui
doit être retravaillé avec les
indications
ça peut être une opportunité et une
approche des syndicats avec le président
de la République avec un engagement fort
de travail commun c'est vrai qu'à moi
c'est beaucoup trop court moi je suis
parfaitement d'accord on peut pas en un
seul mois sur un sujet aussi important
je pense à la pénibilité où j'ai eu des
propos assez qui me sont personnelles
mais quand on m'explique sur le sur les
éboueurs par exemple qui ont une
espérance de vie de 62 ans que donc il
faut absolument qu'il y a de la retraite
à 57 ans moi j'appelle ça du cynisme je
dis qu'il faut qu'il change de métier à
45 ans et qu'on leur donne les moyens
non non je dis qu'on leur donne vraiment
un éboueur qui a 57 ans va retrouver
il y a des métiers il y a des métiers
non justement mais peut-être 35 ans
c'est peut-être des vrais sujets où il
faut vraiment changer l'approche qu'on a
sur certains métiers qui sont tellement
vraiment pénible que il faut les arrêter
beaucoup plus tôt mais donner les moyens
à ceux qui vivent ces métiers
moi je viens du monde du travail il y a
5 ans j'étais pas un homme politique
et moi je garantis qu'on ne peut pas
avoir ce sinistre si les métiers sont si
pénible il faut vraiment les transformer
il faut vraiment trouver des solutions
qui nous permettent clairement c'est un
éclairé franchement rapidement je
propose au président de la République de
dire clairement même si les syndicats
veulent pas le voir qu'il annonce un
Grenelle social qu'il annonça Grenelle
social qu'ils disent que toutes les
conditions de travail le partage de la
valeur les conditions de travail etc et
un certain nombre d'éléments sur la
retraite puisse être mis sur la table si
n'ouvre pas le dialogue en baisse les
syndicats voudront venir à Grenelle
social si la retraite à 64 ans est
promulguée et maintenu bon il faut
mettre quelque chose il faut les
Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas les grands
messes sociales
dans des positions
c'est que cette décision donc il y a une
décision juridique on le rappelle un
mécané conséquences politique bien sûr
le conforte dans ces certitudes c'est
laquelle Emmanuel Macron pensait que de
toute façon d'abord ce que vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est vrai qu'il
l'avait promis pendant sa compagne donc
il avait annoncé la couleur il pensait
qu'il fallait taper vite et fort parce
qu'une réforme des retraites est
toujours un populaire et donc il décide
de la faire à la hussarde en disant ben
voilà c'est comme ça et pas autrement et
ça marche donc je ne vois pas en quoi il
n'a pas donné ni lui ni et des habits de
bande peut-être un peu plus dans les
confidences qu'elle a livré la semaine
dernière au journal Le Monde il y a
quelques autres titres d'entreprises
mais il n'a pas donné un seul moment le
sentiment qu'il voyait qu'il y avait une
crise sociale une crise politique je
suis pas certain qu'on puisse pas de
crise démocratique en tout cas pour lui
il y avait le camp de l'irresponsabilité
c'était ces mots donc caricaturant les
positions de tous ceux qui étaient
opposés ou critiques ont cette réforme
du côté des irresponsables et puis le le
camp de la raison qui était la sienne là
sa réforme passe elle est validée elle
va permettre non seulement d'équilibrer
les pensions selon lui dans 20 ans mais
en plus la une des motivations de cette
réforme c'était quand même de faire
travailler les gens deux ans de plus
pour que pendant 2 ans de plus il paye
des impôts et donc que ça dégage des
marges pour le gouvernement ça n'a
jamais été expliqué comme ça mais c'est
aussi le cas donc je vois pas pourquoi
il remettraient en cause sa méthode
puisque a priori il ne voit pas le
problème et que la méthode brutale
marche donc il y a un risque peut-être
que ça le pousse à continuer comme ça
alors deux informations d'abord la
réaction de la première ministre
Elisabeth borne qui nous dit il y a ce
soir ni vainqueur ni vaincu après la
validation de la réforme et le
gouvernement veut désormais poursuivre
la concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux sur le travail je propose à
tam-tam qui doit être juste derrière le
rideau dans les coulisses de sens public
de nous deux roues de nous rejoindre Tam
puisque voilà on est on est en direct et
en temps réel on digère et on vous fait
participer et on vous propose les
détails de la décision voilà le ma
digestion actuelle alors donc
effectivement une validation pour
l'essentiel de la réforme des retraites
notamment l'article 7 le report de l'âge
légal de 62 à 64 ans si on se plonge
dans ce que dit et bien le Conseil
constitutionnel il y avait deux motifs
pour avoir une invalidation totale le
premier c'était de dire qu'il y avait eu
un détournement du véhicule législatif
du projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale il
dit et bien non pas de recours
irrégulier l'autre possibilité c'était
une atteinte substantielle aux exigences
de clarté et de sincérité des débats là
encore il tranche il dit non il n'y a
pas eu d'atteinte substantielles aux
exigences de clarté et de sincérité
quant à l'accumulation des procédures on
avait parlé 47 1 44 3 articles 38
règlement du Sénat 49-3 etc il se dit il
souligne qu'il y a bien un caractère
inhabituel du recours à toutes ces
procédures mais cela ne pose pas de
problème même constitutionnel alors
concernant la censure partielle il y a
bien six dispositions dont l'index
senior qui sont donc censurés donc c'est
l'article 2 l'index senior l'article 3
donc le CDI senior qui avait été apporté
par la droite sénatoriale on se rappelle
il y a aussi ensuite au centre un peu
plus dans le détail l'article 6 sur
certaines modalités de recouvrement des
cotisations sociales l'article 10 sur et
bien le départ anticipé de certaines
catégories de fonctionnaires l'article
17 on en avait parlé c'est bien ce qui
touche à la pénibilité là encore il y a
certaines dispositions de l'article 17
qui sont on n'a pas exactement le détail
de ce disposition mais qui sont
concernés et puis enfin l'article 27 qui
instaure un dispositif d'informations à
destination des assurés sur le système
de retraite par répartition quant au
rejet du Rip du rythme numéro 1 et bien
il y a bien eu la précision que le
problème qui était posé c'est que le riz
peut tel qu'il était
défendu par la gauche ne constituait pas
une réforme car aujourd'hui à l'instant
T là je légale de départ à la retraite
reste à 62 ans et le rip version numéro
1 disait juste et bien il faut pas que
ça aille au-delà de 62 ans ce qui est
déjà le cas donc c'était déjà satisfait
et donc pas considéré comme une réforme
d'où la deuxième mouture qui a été posée
qui sera examinée on aura la décision
merci beaucoup Tam pour toutes ces
précisions sur peut-être Mathieu un mot
sur le la question de l'insinsérité des
des débats c'était peut-être là que que
le Conseil constitutionnel pouvait ou
non faire de la politique d'une certaine
façon sachant qu'il n'a jamais le
Conseil constitutionnel invoquer cette
cette raison là pour pour censurer un
texte jusqu'à présent c'est une question
qui pour le coup était très
interprétatif pour ne pas dire subjectif
parce qu'on peut considérer que les
débats n'ont pas été clairs ni sincère
encore faut-il le prouver en droit et
pour le coup le recours aux outils
constitutionnels successifs peut
paraître ce que je les ai tout à l'heure
à la hussarde mais c'est constitutionnel
c'est un choix assumé de faire ça au pas
de charge et comme ça avec des votes
bloqué pour pour pouvoir aller plus vite
mais sur la clarté d'insincérité des bas
il y a une question qui est posée en
fait c'est il n'y avait pas besoin
d'études d'impact pour un PLFSS r c'est
un point un projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale rectificatif il y
a pas besoin d'étude d'impact le
gouvernement avait fait d'un premier
document qui n'était pas complet en tout
cas qui n'était pas exact on l'a vu
vérifie ensuite par là sur la question
notamment de qui elle est touché ce
fameux pension minimale et puis il y a
pas non plus de déco de documents
récapitulatif après la CMP qui puisse
montrer l'étude d'impact pourquoi c'est
important parce que c'est important pour
les assurer c'est important pour les
futurs retraités personne aujourd'hui de
dire aux futurs retraités précisément ce
qu'ils vont toucher on en est pas encore
là il y a pas il y a pas d'études qui
résument de façon assez claire et je
mets au défi qui compte ici autour de
cette table puisse dire je suis j'ai
commencé ma carrière à 16 ans voilà
parce que de toute façon les c'est un
sujet compliqué c'est des règles
générales pour des situations
personnelles complexes on le sait mais
en tout cas
le caractère insère des débats n'est pas
prouvé mais il y a quand même cet angle
mort de est-ce qu'on a mis tous les
éléments sur la table pour discuter
Martin lévrier qu'est-ce qui va se
passer maintenant le président de la
République va promulguer cette réforme
ce texte assez vite ça peut l'imaginer
ça me paraît de soi je ne sais pas le
prénom de la République je ne sais pas
ce que je découvre comme vous les
informations donc enfin ça me paraît
assez logique c'est ce que vous
souhaitez c'est la suite logique moi ça
me paraît logique oui j'ai voté cette
loi je dis participé
donc oui elle me paraît nécessaire je
n'arrête pas de dire depuis le début
alors je l'ai pas dit comme tout le
monde mais j'ai d'abord parlé de courage
de demande d'effort aux Français je
crois qu'on l'a pas assez dit de notre
côté qu'on demandait un effort et que
parler de justice etc peut-être mais
avant tout c'était un effort qu'on
demandait à un certain nombre de
Français mais c'est une réforme de
courage et c'est une réforme qui fallait
faire et je dis je le redis je la
compare par exemple au numerus clausus
sont dans la santé
cette réforme de nuage plus avait été
fait il y a 25 ans il aurait fallu un
peu de courage et si ça avait été fait
nous serons pas dans la difficulté dans
la difficulté que nous avons aujourd'hui
et donc des réformes courageux il faut
bien les faire et des réformes qui ne
plaisent pas à tout le monde si on ne
devait faire que des réformes qui
plaisent aux gens aux Français ou dans
d'autres pays mais mon dieu ce serait le
déclassement systématique il le courage
est important et ça me démontre bien
qu'on fait une réforme qui n'est pas une
réforme qui nous fera réélire c'est pas
l'objectif donc c'est vraiment du
courage et c'est du courage au service
des Français c'est pas du courage pour
faire plaisir vous parliez il y a de
deux secondes et ça m'a fait réagir le
gouvernement va se donner des marges de
manoeuvre mais le gouvernement doit
gérer une politique de crise avec un
déficit colossé
c'est un mot si vous voulez qui est
important les marges de manœuvre c'est
simplement pour sortir de ce déficit qui
est colossal pour redonner la confiance
aux Français et l'investissement
possible c'est un c'est très important
aux français mais aussi aux partenaires
européens et aux investisseurs et aux
Américains il y a aussi tout ça mais oui
enfin je vous rappelle quand même que
c'est c'est le gouv ernement Macron 1
qui a remis la France dans les clous de
l'Europe en 2017 c'était quand même le
plus important donc la bonne gestion on
sait de quoi on parle on sait vraiment
de quoi on parle mais la bonne gestion
c'est essentiel aussi
est-ce que vous vous donnez qui tu sais
Emmanuel Macron on a certains courage
politique
le courage politique c'est effectivement
faire les réformes de ce côté là moi
j'étais favorable je le dis tout de
suite au 64 ans ou 43 Z8 j'aurais pas
conduit la réforme comme ça ça c'est sûr
parce que j'aurais mis la loi travail la
réforme des retraites en même temps et
j'en aurai fait un axe fort de la
négociation avec les syndicats pour voir
ce qu'il pouvait être trouvé comme
amélioration donc c'est plus la forme la
manière et au final tout ce qui fait
l'environnement de la réforme elle-même
qui n'a pas été traitée ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que je reconnais que naturellement nous
avons des dettes considérables un
déficit considérable mais bon après le
quoi qu'il en coûte après le quel que
soit le prix on aurait dû expliquer
différemment la réforme des retraites
clairement on a voulu on a raison
politique simple c'est que comme les
républicains avaient eux-mêmes dans leur
programme précédent dit 65 quand
Emmanuel Macron s'était dit bah pas de
problème j'ai la majorité au Sénat
j'aurais la majorité à l'Assemblée
puisque LR plus Renaissance ça fait la
majorité sauf que chez l'air de
l'Assemblée ça n'a pas marché résultat
du car 9.3 résultat du 47 ans résultat
toutes les les formes qui ont été mises
en place mais tout ça est pas
suffisamment discuté et négociant en
amont y compris avec nous enfin tout
tout ça est un peu surréaliste moi je
propose au président de la République de
continuer d'essayer de continuer à faire
d'effort parce que on dit tout ça sauf
que moi je pense que le texte va être
promulgué je vois pas ce qui peut faire
d'autre mais quid du texte immigration
quid du texte justice quid de tous les
textes qui devaient arriver là et dont
on se dit politiquement maintenant tout
est extraordinairement compliqué et ça
ne passera pas la première ministre
c'est en qui plus est engagait le plus
utilisé le 49-3 ce qui d'ailleurs pardon
de le dire j'ai conduit la réforme de
2008 au nom du Président Sarkozy qui a
réduit le 49-3 mais c'est une folie pour
un gouvernement de dire à l'avance je
n'utiliserai plus le 49-3 ça c'est ce
tirer une balle dans le pied si on n'a
pas de majorité ce qui est le cas bon et
bien Assassin's qui va sans doute se
passer c'est effectivement une
promulgation assez rapide par le
Président de la République et puis en
parallèle va y avoir la procédure autour
du référendum d'initiative partagée
parce que même si le premier il faut
bien expliquer ça a été retoqué bon il y
a une seconde mouture qui qui est arrivé
on verra bien ce que le Conseil
consignait le décide le 3 mai mais bon
imaginons qu'il y a un référendum en
cours avec l'obligation de d'obtenir les
signatures de 10% du col du corps
électoral il y a quoi il y a une
mobilisation syndicale qui va continuer
éternellement pendant trois six neuf
mois combien de temps ça va durer s'il y
a d'abord un mois j'inviterai si je peux
me permettre le président de la
République bien évidemment qu'il doit
promulguer la loi mais on connaît on
connaît on a des pages d'histoire qui
nous disent que des lois promulguées
s'éteignent telle même donc bien
évidemment il peut promener la loi moi
je l'inviterai quand même à ne la
promulguer qu'après la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel sur le rip de
il est dans les 15 jours c'est 15 jours
ça peut ça peut être dans les dans les
trois quatre jours quoi
[Musique]
donc acte pour les les 15 jours qui
seront passés mais si il y a acceptation
effectivement validation par le Conseil
constitutionnel donc de la deuxième
version du riz parce que nous savions
bien que le rip 1 ne faisait pas réforme
si je peux aller visiter donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle
il y avait une erreur dans la dans la
façon d'écrire le la première
proposition on a beaucoup discuté on a
beaucoup négocié aussi et justement sur
cette éventualité de faire un RIP 2 et
au bout des discussions est arrivé cette
proposition qui donne à peu plus de
Saturne à cette demande du rythme qui en
fait une vraie réforme donc si il y a
acceptation validation par le Conseil
constitutionnel bien évidemment il va y
avoir une grande bataille de proximité
avec les citoyens et les citoyens parce
que je rappelle que seuls les électrices
et les électeurs peuvent participer à
cette initiative elle participerait à la
campagne pour pour les signatures
avec le référendum sur sur ADP donc on a
un savoir-faire quand même on a des
savoirs et des savoir-faire
de fausses promesses aux Français non
plus c'est pas parce qu'il y a 5
millions de signatures qui a forcément
un référendum au bout il faut déjà
recueillir les plus de 4,7 millions
d'électricité et et des lecteurs ensuite
que se passe-t-il donc on a 9 mois et
peut-être s'il y avait validation du Rib
je pense qu'on pourrait arriver avant
les 9 mois au cadre de virgule 7
millions de de recueil de signatures
ensuite soit une proposition de loi et
décider et d'adopter présenter au
Parlement et voter au Parlement qui
risqueraient de la rotoquer on va passer
d'illusions soit le président au bout de
6 mois s'il ma mémoire est bonne au bout
de 6 mois le prix si elle n'a pas été
examinée le président de la République
déclenche un référendum tout ça on le
référendum n'est pas automatique à
partir du moment où le 3 mai le Conseil
constitutionnel rend sa décision oui
mais il faut bien le dire ce qui nous
amène à l'été 2024
c'est une respiration démocratique
dans le moment que nous vivons
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est ça là on
est dans les enjeux politiques mais
pensez un peu au futur retraités mais
oui qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour les
gens qui vont être soumis aux nouvelles
règles à partir de septembre qui vont se
dire est-ce que je prends ma retraite je
la reprends pas risque peut-être de ta
nuit comment les gens vont s'y retrouver
c'est vrai qu'on a deux logiques
parallèles une logique parlementaire
équilibrée qui a été validé et par le
Conseil constitutionnel avec une loi
promulguée et une logique que j'allais
dire plus populaire mais même si elle
s'inscrit dans un chemin institutionnel
et j'ai un moment il faut penser quand
même aux gens concernés c'est-à-dire on
peut faire des coups politiques on peut
essayer
Emmanuel Macron peut se dire je suis
passé en forge j'ai réussi mon pari
banco l'opposition peut dire bon on va
faire le rip pour essayer de le
contourner mais il y a des gens quand
même au bout qu'est-ce que vous dites
qui doivent qui doivent prendre leur
retraite et faire leur calcul à partir
de la rentrée prochaine pour ça que je
suis beaucoup plus près et je pose une
autre question on parle depuis tout à
l'heure aussi du renforcement de la vie
démocratique en France et donc du
Parlement
un référendum c'est une question binaire
le sujet de les retraites vous l'avez
dit alors est un sujet excessivement
complexe et c'est au rôle du Parlement
parce que nous avons nous le temps et
nous sommes payés pour ça j'allais dire
de faire toutes les études possibles
toutes les écoutes possibles toutes les
auditions possibles toutes les auditions
posées mais nous on nous faisons des
auditions et bien heureusement et tout
ce travail c'est le rôle des
parlementaires et ensuite de prendre une
décision éclairée en tant que
parlementaire pour renforcer la
démocratie cette loi a été faite ainsi
parler du parler d'un rythme pareil
sur les retraites un référendum me
paraît
une forme de cynisme j'allais dire parce
que la question est tellement complexe
qu'on peut pas la rendre binaire et une
fine et je vous rejoins complètement il
faut aussi penser à tous les retraités
qui vont avoir des augmentations de
pension tel que prévu dans la loi
imaginez que cette loi soit annulée deux
ans après on va leur demander de
rembourser moi je n'y crois pas
de voilà moi je comprends très bien que
la stratégie qui consiste à dire
nous n'avons pas la majorité au
Parlement le Conseil constitent valide
le texte allons-y allons-y allons au
référendum non non mais attendez sauf
que franchement vous êtes le
gouvernement vous êtes la majorité
relative à l'Assemblée imaginons même
qu'il y a 4,8 millions bah immédiatement
vous inscrivez une proposition de loi au
Parlement il n'y a pas de raison
franchement que ça donne un résultat
différent de celui que ça a donné ce qui
veut dire que le texte sera rejeté à
l'Assemblée nationale et à partir de là
il y a plus de référendum donc c'est une
fausse promesse je pense que je leur ai
fait un dogme d'initiative populaire n'a
en réalité une chance d'être fait pour
le moment il y en a jamais eu donc on a
assez
tranquillement mais non si il fallait le
mettre mais en réalité on imaginait
l'utilisation du Rip sur des textes qui
n'étaient pas déjà passé au Parlement
c'est ça la complexité du du système
c'est qu'en réalité le gouvernement ou
la majorité parlementaire pouvait très
bien ne pas vouloir inscrire un sujet
qui dans l'opinion était prégnant donc
mais là vous avez un texte qui est déjà
passé au Parlement donc il y a déjà eu
la confrontation non mais il y a déjà eu
la confrontation de discuter il faut
trouver il faut trouver l'ouverture de
la discussion des mots pratiques
d'accord
considère qu'il y a une crise
aujourd'hui ou non si le pouvoir
exécutif ne considère pas qu'il y a une
crise ils vont continuer comme avant si
on cherche un déboucher politique une
porte de sortie qui humilie personne qui
permette aux gens de se reparler on dit
bah oui il y a une crise et on essaie de
la résoudre mais pour l'instant
l'exécutif nous dit il y a pas de crise
donc pour pour qu'il y ait une envie ou
une volonté de sortie crise il faut que
tout le monde bouge des mouvements au
thé je suis désolé les syndicats à
l'heure qu'il est n'ont fait aucun
mouvement aucun ils ont proposé une
médiation ils ont proposé mais une
médiation en partant du principe qu'il
était hors de question de toucher à
l'âge
c'est pas le début de négociation ça
fait longtemps qu'on négocie alors je
suis sur les portes de sortie
éventuelles regardez ce sondage
Ipsos sopra Steria sur parmi la question
posée parmi les trois possibilités
suivantes laquelle à votre préférence
une dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
de nouvelles élections législatives 45%
des personnes interrogées répondent opte
pour cette solution un remaniement du
gouvernement et un changement de Premier
ministre 38% et le maintien d'Elisabeth
borde je sais pas si on a l'infographie
il semblerait que non le maintien
d'Elisabeth borne comme première
ministre à 17% on a peut-être des petits
soucis avec les infographies c'est pas
très grave je vous propose d'écouter
parce que si on parle de remaniement il
y a un nom qui sort de temps en temps et
que vous connaissez bien ici c'est celui
de Gérard Larcher le président du Sénat
il répondait à cette question
hier chez nos confrères de BFM TV
et la manière de gouverner d'Emmanuel
Macron est interrogé par cette crise
comme elle l'avait été au moment des
gilets jaunes comme elle a été à un
moment de la crise sanitaire c'est aussi
une crise liée au déficit du dialogue
social qui n'a pas commencé qu'au moment
des retraites et qui et six années
j'allais dire d'affaiblissement du
dialogue social alors
aujourd'hui comment on sort de la crise
d'abord par un temps d'apaisement bien
évidemment mais il faut aussi traiter
les causes profondes de la crise est-ce
que il ne faut pas se poser la question
sur la bannière de gouverner c'est ça
appartient au chef de l'État bon il n'a
pas répondu non
plus aujourd'hui
de cette solution Roger caoutchi non je
veux pas dire ça moi parce que comme je
suis premier vice-président tout le
monde job évidemment
voir la suite non non non non non non
c'est pas le sujet le sujet le sujet
c'est la vie
genre l'archer
une telle carrière qu'il n'y a pas au
Matignon par ambition personnelle il ne
peut aller à Matignon que si le
président de la République changer la
donne sociale politique etc est-ce que
le Président de la République à cette
intention à mon avis aujourd'hui je sais
pas dans quelques temps aujourd'hui non
donc le problème ne se pose pas comme ça
après c'est la décision de Gérard
Larcher mais en fonction des contacts
qui peuvent avoir le Président je sens
pas les choses aller dans ce sens
immédiatement
sur le papier le profil de Gérard quand
même pas mal de cases
avec les partenaires sociaux c'est
quelqu'un qui a une crédibilité sur le
sujet genre l'archer il faut rappeler
que a été mise en relation sociale puis
la ministre du Travail et qu'il a mené
cette réforme
pour renouer le lien avec les élus
locaux ah bah non plus le fort de la
macronie voilà pour trouver les 40 voies
qui manquent à l'Assemblée à droite ce
serait peut-être pas fait de façon
automatique mais en tout cas il serait
bien placé après si Gérard Larcher c'est
une cohabitation qui ne dit pas son nom
donc on est dans un autre dans un autre
cas de figure politique ça voudrait dire
dans ces cas-là mais là on fait de la
politique fiction non pas une
cohabitation mais une coalition or cette
coalition politique elle a tristement
est bien malheureusement échoué sur la
réforme des retraites parce que autant
le dialogue c'est bien passé au Sénat
entre la droite le centre et nous et
vraiment bien et intelligent tout
intelligence pardon malheureusement
on n'avancera pas parce que vous êtes
toujours sur le thème de ce qu'a dit le
président de la République qu'a dit le
Premier ministre je veux élargir la
majorité c'est pas le sujet on ne veut
pas être un élargissement de majorité on
vous dit il faut un autre projet c'est
pas la même chose excusez-moi mais le
projet que vous avez porté il est il a
fait 4 %. donc on va pas s'en sortir
comme ça non plus ça marche pas pour
être intelligent faut dépasser faut
faire un peu l'allemand vous voyez
l'Allemagne et là on y arriverait
peut-être mais c'est vrai que ça demande
une révolution culturelle de certains
tous les jours je redonne je redonne le
sondage on l'a retrouvé génial merci à
tous en régie sur les sur les options et
la réaction des des Français donc
dissolution 45% remaniement du
gouvernement changement de Premier
ministre 38% maintien d'Élisabeth borde
comme première Miss
17%, il y en a ça si on va terminer avec
vous est-ce que finalement il le fera
pas mais la vraie la seule solution
logique ce serait la dissolution dans la
vraie solution logique c'est le retrait
de la réforme je suis désolé ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas une une dissolution
merci beaucoup merci à tous
premier débat de sens public